bonjour ni la fin après 43 jours
maintenant de mobilisation les
manifestants ont répondu présent
mais effectivement sophie les
manifestants ont répondu présent ils
sont déjà plusieurs centaines de
personnes ici ou par montparnasse se
sont donné rendez vous à 13h30 devant là
nous aurons par la symbolique est donc
là dans le corps des gi's toutes les
conditions il ya des enseignants il ya
des étudiants il ya des personnels aux
montagnes et d'ailleurs je suis avec le
docteur bendjelloul bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
missions avec halo 3 jours de grève vous
restait déterminée à tout mettre en
oeuvre pour venir le recréer je pense
que le gênera quelle que soit la forme
de lutte qui va se perpétuer parce que
ça change
mais il faudra absolument car il est au
contraire
c'est un mouvement inédit pour sa durée
et sa ténacité et je pense qu'on finira
par l'obtenir
même si aujourd'hui 3 féminine est
autiste ne pas entendre ce qui se passe
alors que le peuple se rebelle depuis
plus d'un an grâce au gilet jaune rien
entendre une bonne crèmerie pour nous et
gazier il emprisonne muller mais la
lutte continue quand même pourtant le
gouvernement a fermé en avant avec le
retrait de la juive au bon non en fait
c'est nous c'est complètement absurde de
voir ça on pense que l'on peut quasiment
9 avril par des lâches des équilibres
lorsqu'il revient exactement au même
en plus la lâche plus beau c'est parce
qu'il s'en remet à la réforme et toutes
choses qui se passent à la réforme à moi
qui ai indiqué
quintiq deux choses très importantes que
turda compris en commun si ce à quoi
nous en ignorant ou des roues de la
racaille et qui ne comprennent rien des
gens de rien nous avons tous compris
qu'ils me font les poches c'est à dire
qu'on va cotiser peut-être un peu plus
les pensions doit être réduite et pour
travailler davantage mais je voudrais
dire quelque chose là dessus c'est que
la réforme des retraites n'a pas
commencé juste 20 ans elle a commencé
l'année dernière par une chose très
importante qui est passé et que les gens
n'ont pas vraiment contester ces îles
ont déjà des pistes d'accès la retraite
de natation alors pour travailler dans
le domaine de la santé c'est un milieu
on retrouve beaucoup de représentants de
ce secteur dans les manifestations
poursuit depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant c'est un milieu qui souffre
pas vraiment ah oui en fait là la santé
sur deux buts 30 ans et particulièrement
de boue plus de dix ans on considère
qu'on ne vendait pas d'abord soigner les
gens on est là pour faire des plans pour
commencer à bâtir avec la déontologie et
la pratique va mais si de façon assez
claire
mais oui et entendu en matière de mode
ce sont aussi bien au niveau des
soignants nous aide soignant plate
fermiers et c'est la catastrophe
les hôpitaux savez ya plus de 480 à
fermer en quelques années jean tirand
fait monter en présence de dénis en
moyenne un poste en moins
vous entendez sophie des maisons qui est
déterminé après deux grèves le cortège
quelques minutes direction à la place
d'italie est effectivement tout ce qui
s'y dit
qui manifesteront jusqu'à ce que cette
réforme des retraites soit tout
simplement risible